hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
unboxing video and in this one we'll be
taking a look at the ds international
power saving power strip so let's get
right on into this guys
all right guys so the ds international
power strip is actually a a product
that's going to help you save a lot of
money first of all uh for your power
costs this is a a power strip obviously
you know is something that has numerous
outlets and one plug and this is
something that's going to help you save
about a hundred dollars per workstation
per year so that's about 16 on
electricity in this box so i'm just
going to show you guys uh my unboxing
and first impressions of what is what
comes in the box uh the ds international
product and they were kind enough to
send this out to me
so pardon for being in the way of the
camera here uh but it is a pretty big
box so let's just get right into this
there we go
there's a bit of paper on top so just
remove the paper
and here's a much smaller ds
international energy saver power strip
box
so as you can tell by the box of course
there are going to be one two three four
uh four secondary outlets in one primary
outlet and i'll get to that obviously in
the review as this is a really easy to
use product that's gonna definitely be
worth your money and save you guys a lot
of money in the long run so here's the
back of the box and just give you guys a
brief demonstration of a little system
workstation there and uh let's go ahead
and open it from this end and see what
we get inside the box
let's pull this out here this is
obviously the white model
and inside the box you get actually a
little manual here this is the
instruction manual gives you all the
information about you know the important
things and the features of the product
of course i'm going to cover these
things in the review of the power strip
and actually give you guys a rundown of
how it's worked for me and whether or
not it's actually saved me electricity
so we'll see about that but yeah here it
is it is white and it is uh the american
version of the outlet as you can see
over here it says intelligent socket
primary and four secondary so this has
the uh
the american socket uh version right
here this is white
and uh that's pretty much it for the
unboxing and first impressions guys so
just a very quick video showing you guys
what comes in the box and the box itself
and i'm going to show you guys um all
the features you need to know about this
power ship and i'll include a link in
the description to the right with all
the information just in case you just
can't wait to watch the review video so
thank you for watching this unboxing
video of the ds international green
energy saving power strip and i will
talk to you guys in the next video peace